oh cab you Larry listen when I was a kid
oh great a narrator when alien life
entered our world it was from deep
beneath the Pacific Ocean Ruby thinks
I'm just gonna accept that
a fissure between two tectonic plates
portal between dimensions honestly if
this is all the harder you're gonna work
to explain the science part of your
fiction don't even explain it just jump
right into the action destruction of the
Golden Gate Bridge when action film
takes place in San Francisco cliche six
days and 35 miles later three cities
were destroyed tens of thousands of
lives were lost I don't mean to be
insensitive but is that all I mean six
full days of that thing we rampaging
through three major cities and only tens
of thousands died those are pretty good
numbers actually should consider
yourself lucky and then the third one
hit Cabo
even the kaiju have to go on spring
break why is the archived footage of the
initial setbacks faced by the Jaeger
program in black and white it was still
filmed in the future right a kid yeah
don't get cocky
probable Star Wars homage ends up
feeling more like a cheesy ripoff we
would never star athletes this mother is
still narrating
Yeager's use inception music to
introduce themselves
okay so just seconds ago you rose up out
of the water completely submerged but
now you're standing in the water and it
comes up to your knees so what position
must gipsy danger have been in
underwater in order to pull up that rise
up from the deep move like lying flat on
the floor of the ocean right oh come on
this cannon loaded up immediately
earlier and now it takes forever to load
seventeen minutes in the movie finally
feels confident it's given you enough
back story to tell the actual story did
you like just watch The Avengers right
before shooting this stuff its powers
booth up there somewhere
give interest Elba an eyepatch and I
could seriously begin to doubt which
movie I'm watching why are you surprised
why is anyone surprised you built a
giant wall to try and keep out something
that eats boats and giant robots for
breakfast shatterdome gipsy danger who
the hell did we put in charge of naming
things in the future
I'm guessing it's someone's
twelve-year-old cousin to me you dead
white dude you have been kaiju in this
movie do we really need a
paint-by-numbers bully as a secondary
antagonist do we really need a label to
know that this is the candidate trials
there's knowing that at 6 a.m. at
anything to our enjoyment of the scene I
made my decision report to the
shatterdome in two hours find out who
your copilot will be is there any reason
at all for the mystery if you've made up
your mind and it's not her then why make
him wait I mean obviously the
screenwriter wants him to wait so that
we can have the big reveal as he changes
his mind and chooses the girl after all
but that's for us the audience there's
no reason for Raleigh not to know or the
actual guy who got picked
well either he's got a nosebleed or
spider-man's on the ceiling of the
elevator trying not to be seen they're
colonists they overtake wait which is it
do they colonize or consume those two
things are not synonymous and now you
know with ozone depletion and carbon
monoxide polluted waters well we've
practically terraformed before the Oh
for fuck's sake even the movie about
giant robots fighting giant alien
monsters has to shove environmental
messages down our throat we're
destroying earth we get it I wanted to
hear about that I definitely wouldn't go
to a giant robot fighting movie this is
actually terrifying and awesome this is
a way better back story than Raleigh's
why isn't she the main character why
doesn't the movie just start with this
and skip all the way away my brother
died crap this whole complex looks
pretty damn big why did the leader end
up with an office that is 40% water how
is it even remotely practical to have a
moat in your office there are no other
rooms in the place that had actual
floors like you know the pilots quarters
do fresh drifts are rough and this is
the quietest Jaeger factory in the
history of Jaeger factories they're
practically whispering with us and why
shouldn't they it's dead silent in this
wait a minute
if the kaiju were only just now
appearing two at a time then why the
hell did they ever need more than a
handful of Yeager's back in the day I
mean the kaiju back then would have been
one at a time coming with much more time
between them it was years ago they were
also a lot smaller so why did we have a
fleet of dozens of acres were they all
doing why does the historical footage
early in the movie show only one or two
jagers at a time fighting a kaiju
it's not like there were multiple kaiju
at once around the world for them to be
all off in different places it's not
like they would have been patrolling
their own sections of the world since
the kaiju always come from the same spot
and that spot is monitored the marshal
says they used to launch 30 jaegers and
are now down to just four how is that
even possible why do they have to fly
these things by helicopter to where the
breach is why didn't they just build
their 30 Jaeger capable launching
facility somewhere you know closer to
the breach so they could just walk out
or and I don't mean to beat a dead horse
here but why not just build some giant
cannons out of the same kind of blue
energy the jaegers are using which seems
to kill kaiju and just set up some
motion-detecting cameras so the guns act
as sentries in boom problem solved okay
so the Chinese Jaeger has three
pilots because it has this fancy three
armed attack mode but with drifting in a
normally anger the movie has shown us
that both pilots move their right arm to
move the robots right arm and both
pilots walk in order to make the legs
move so how does adding a third pilot to
the Chinese Jaeger enable them to
collectively move a third arm all the
pilots are presumably drifting together
as a threesome but none of them actually
have third arms and if it's possible to
divide the arms up among pilots then why
go through all the motions to show the
other Jaeger pilots have to move their
arms and legs in tandem is there any
need to drift at all if you can just add
a third pilot to control the third arm
two of its three active Yeager's are
completely gone instead of sending
wall-e and ma Co to suit up immediately
the marshal just grimaces see like these
cannons
is there any particularly reason these
cannons have to be mounted on a giant
robot could you not just line the entire
breech area with automated versions of
these things just like most movie
villains the kaiju ignore their perfect
opportunity to finish Stryker and one of
them even swims away I don't know how
many minutes are supposed to have passed
and Stryker went dead in the water but
since then the other kaiju has been
pacing around them but also Rolly talked
the marshal into letting them go out
they got suited up got the nuclear power
gipsy danger all fired up strapped into
the helicopters and flew that thing out
to Hong Kong City Harbor that's way too
much to have gone down in just a handful
of minutes kind of convenient that the
kaiju didn't use any of the awesome new
attacks on gipsy that had been so
effective on the other three Yeager's
instead he just tries to mostly wrestle
this time and he pays for it ah next box
one was in there the second kaiju has
been really inefficient in his
destruction of the city while all this
was going on I mean yeah there's some
flames there but honestly I'm surprised
there are any tall buildings at all
still standing couldn't he just run back
and forth in a lawnmower pattern and
have the whole thing licked in 60
seconds how can you possibly lose track
of a kaiju this is even worse than when
the military kept losing track of
Godzilla ah
melty blue acid spread cool why don't
they use that all the time is there none
of the acid left inside the kaijus mouth
shouldn't Gypsys fingers get melted off
now the computer says it's venting the
coolant before marco actually pushes the
button is the sword new did Rolly not
know about it and if so why did they not
tell it
wait this is how close the shatterdome
is to Hong Kong City like literally
right on the harbor and yet they still
took the time to hook up and
fly each Jaeger by helicopter this is
like literally six Jaeger steps from
where the helicopters were dropping them
off these assholes are celebrating like
it's the end of Star Wars but really
half their pilots are dead along with
tens of thousands of civilians of Hong
Kong City it's right we don't have
nearly enough similarities to Godzilla
in this movie let's add some more main
character trips and falls while running
away from evil cliche where did the
mathematician come from he wasn't with
the only Sonny guy throughout the entire
ordeal he just magically appears right
here at the spot of the baby kaiju death
that no one could have predicted he's
standing on the dock of the shatterdome
with everyone else just a little bit ago
so did the always Sonny guy call the
base tell them about the dead baby kind
you and request the help of the
mathematician he can't stand and then
wait while they flew that guy out there
by helicopter and only then say he's got
dialogue perfectly timed to coincide
with silly revealed that surprises only
the characters in the movie the two
scientists decide they need to warn the
jaegers that their plan won't work and
decide the best way to tell them is by
helicopter instead of a radio phone
smoke signal all of which would have
been faster this guy juice able to sneak
up on gipsy even though the Homebase
people were clearly monitoring their
position and movement just a few seconds
ago
remember that was a 2400 ton bomb I'm
impressed they built gipsy danger out of
materials that can withstand a nuclear
blast that size in close proximity that
think survived a nuke up close I know
it's a category 5 but they just took
down a category 4 with a sword
oh yeah the radios still work even
though these guys are in an alternate
alien dimension hey boss how many
choppers should we send out to pick up
the two survivors all of them where's my
god damn you see this is why it's a bad
thing when every movie has to have an
end credits scene because some of them
don't know what the hell to do with it
and they give you a useless like this
[Music]
we would never star athletes
where the hell's got ears it's funny
lieutenant Diane said that because right
then God showed
everyone listen up
it is true what many of you have heard
as I speak that army is drawing nearer
to our home believe me when I say we
have a difficult time ahead of us but if
we are to be prepared for it we must
first shed our fearless
I remember that which matters most we
are still we're walking nuclear reactor
we're sitting on four million tons of
fuel one nuclear weapon and a thing that
has 270,000 moving parts don't find the
lowest bidder